yeah I would say for me like the
political Matrix there's a couple
different things and I usually don't use
terms like the red pill or the Matrix
for the reason that you described which
is that they're thrown around by so many
people to represent so many different
things but I would say that in one sense
The Matrix is sort of like all the the
social political ideas that are forced
onto people that they're convinced of
that are untrue and I would say one of
those at least in the dating Marketplace
is just you know the sexual Revolution
more generally speaking this idea that
people are happy when they have sex
outside of marriage that this is
something that people should aspire to
do and that it's a healthy way for man
to live and that we're just a product of
our own self-invention and as long as a
person is getting their sexual
gratification what they're doing is
beyond reproach basically
that's Matrix yeah that's definitely
Matrix that's like I would say so I
don't usually use that language yeah
that's how I was wondering but no
because well but it's also political
because the sexual Revolution is a
massively uh political thing it has a
strong political element to it and all
of our political establishments exactly
promote it it's a mix of the the like
it's a mix of the political and dating
yeah yeah well because the family is the
building block of society so anything
the movement has to well Reagan played a
role in the destruction of the American
family with no fault divorce he didn't
do it himself overnight man there was a
lot at work there but um I think it was
that was a misstep it was it's it's hard
to say with the final nails but that was
definitely very bad very bad no fault no
fault divorce ended marriage it
formalized our it formalized our ending
of marriage but there were other things
like there was a massive cultural shift
that happened at this time so previously
people thought of divorce as something
that was horrible but that we should
allow in certain circumstances and I'm
not even saying that's the correct
vision because my I I just don't believe
a marriage can actually end if it's an
actual marriage but that's not to say
somebody's being abused can't go live
somewhere else but my main point is
there was there was uh there was a there
was a uh reinvention that happened
culturally or around the time of the
1970s where people stopped viewing
divorce as this unfortunate thing that
happened sometimes and that we should
allow a political outlet for and they
started reframing it as an adventure a
method of self-exploration a way to
reinvent yourself rather than like
something horrific that we should
prevent from from ever well I mean some
people say it's um birth control if you
look up yeah divorce rate and like birth
control like the rate of women on birth
control it's really interesting the the
charts are the same pretty much wow yeah
well it all plays a role you could look
it up and like put it on the screen it's
really interesting it's like literally
if you put them side by side it's the
same I know that uh but I would smell
different I would say like social media
too because I I think like yeah because
I mean you get like all these women that
think they're hotter than they are
because they have the simps messaging
them every single day Instagram filters
yeah so I think like it would be silly
to not include that in like the
destruction of the family but also is
that the destruction these women can't
these women still hook up with those
Sims that are messaging them what do you
mean like
what about the fact that guys are
hitting on these women is different from
reality because it may it made a global
sexual Marketplace so it's not she
doesn't just have access to the men like
in her town because before it's like the
prettiest guy prettiest girl in the town
marry each other whatever now it's like
the men are competing with men from you
know Dubai like celebrities like how
many women has you know a celebrity like
Drake slept with we actually future
future wives you know what I mean we've
talked a lot about this uh yeah I've and
boy it doesn't trigger the feminists I
talked about how uh dating apps oh
that's basically caused a major collapse
because what happens is it used to be
that if you were a dude you had access
men and women had access to their school
basically the institution where they
spent all their time so a guy is 18 he
goes to college and he has access to the
women in the college network which is
mostly the college he's at and then
maybe the friends of friends yeah but
when dating apps emerge all of a sudden
all of these you know 18 plus young
women have access to 25 year old plus
men who aren't in college but have cars
have jobs have salary days and now the
18 year old in college has to enter has
to compete with a guy who's already got
a career and is already established and
they can't yeah I think it's it's really
important that you pointed out birth
control because that plays a massive
role in the way that we've been
restructured in terms of our thinking
about sexuality so people used to
recognize that the purpose of sex was
unity and procreation right and you
wanted to be with the person you were
going to be with the rest of your life
before you engage in that act with them
because it makes new people and someone
has to take responsibility for those new
people what artificial contraceptives
made possible was a rerouting of our
Collective cultural thinking about
sexuality which took it from something
that was to be revered that was
beautiful that needed social
restrictions and something that was just
about the pleasure of the individual and
that only needed to be considered within
the context of pleasure without actually
considering its actual broader purpose
which is the creation of families and of
course families are the building block
of society so when you corrupt people's
sexual morals you end up destroying the
entire Society inevitably I mean if you
don't end up setting that that train
back on the the rail or putting things
back in the proper course it all falls
apart you you just can't do it
um and you know we recognize this
economically whenever a Marketplace is
deregulated we say well this is going to
result in unbearable inequalities all of
the spoils will go to some small
percentage of people who happen to have
the traits that the market rewards but
then when it came to the sexual
Revolution no one was willing to say
that well when it comes to the sexual
Marketplace deregulating it is going to
create unbearable inequalities and in
the end people aren't going to be happy
I get the feeling that if we made birth
control illegal and made abortion
illegal it would cause Devastation like
it would cause a bunch of spousal abuse
like a lot of the the value of I can't
stand no-fault divorce I mean it makes
me I lost faith in marriage basically I
have no faith in that institution
because she can leave whenever she wants
but if they're stuck then won't they
just be getting beat a lot
um so if well this is the whole point of
no fault divorce is a person could get
divorced if they demonstrated that there
was some kind of abuse occurring right
and this is part of what I was saying
earlier I believe marriage is lifelong
but that doesn't mean that you can't go
live somewhere else if a person is
abusing you right that doesn't mean you
don't go and go to the police well and
the one thing too they've expanded the
definition of abuse so much that we
don't even know what abuse is anymore
like it's not just like that you can
include like Financial abuse because I'm
doing a divorce documentary and and so
um it's going into like basically men
that get financially ruined by divorce
and the issue is like they literally
like have expanded the definition so
much to include things like Financial
abuse so if I'm married and he says you
can't spend five thousand dollars on my
credit card he's financially controlling
me and that's considered abuse and
family court so it's very sweet you need
to give in the US percentage of your
income UK um us is state by state wow so
like this is this is based in the UK
those are violence now so yeah exactly
do you think there's faith in marriage
do you have faith in marriage well I
don't think marriage is marriage anymore
like I I think that marriage it's a
whole different institution it's
basically just long-term relationships
nowadays it's dating I think that's
there's truth in that yeah because like
if you can get out like how is it
marriage I think the way is marriage
doesn't exist since no-fault divorce
yeah I I would argue that in the United
States our laws don't properly recognize
marriage of course I believe marriage
still exists but the way the culture
understands it you're not looking at
actual marriages in a sense because the
person isn't truly saying uh For Better
or For Worse till death do we part
they're saying I'm just going to do this
for a while until I get bored about like
if if divorce is in your mind as an
option it's something you're willing to
consider and you're not saying there is
no one else for me for the rest of my
life or this person's life then are you
really getting married there's uh in the
service industry I used to work as a
waiter for like a decade and when we
would finish a shift I'd marry the
condiments and be like okay take the
ketchups and marry them together which
means mix I'd pour one into the other
shake it up you could never undo that
that mix is permanent now one flesh the
two became one flesh and what what does
a guy get out of marriage that he
doesn't get out of a long-term
girlfriend if she can leave her half her
money yeah well again I think the um
they won't even have her money I guess
in the instance of like was it the story
with Russell Brand that when they got he
got divorced from Katy Perry he didn't
take anything from her because they're
both super rich and he didn't care yeah
well I mean but women get money the
majority of the time so it's not like
men get money out of it yeah yeah like I
think I think women only get spousal
support like 10 of the time when it
comes to child like child custody women
get the kids 90 of the time yeah so it's
really an unfair system totally agreed
and so you're as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible